- [Voiceover] What I
hope to do in this video
is a bunch of examples to show us that
a lot of the properties
we've been dealing with
in arithmetic, the distributive property,
associative property,
commutative property,
that these apply just as
well to negative numbers.
But with that said, it is
good to actually see it used
using negative numbers,
or see these properties applied
just to make sure that we
understand what's going on.
So these exercises, these
are all from Kahn Academy.
Oops.
So this first one says,
which of the following
expressions are equivalent
to negative two times the
quantity five minus three?
Now you could, of course, just figure out
that five minus three is two and then
multiply that times negative two
and you would get negative four.
And you could see which of
these is equal to negative four.
And that would be fair, but
the whole point of this video
is to understand that
look, maybe I could apply
the distributive property here.
So let's do that.
So what I could do is I could
distribute this negative two.
I could multiply it times five
and then I could multiply it by,
I could either do it as it's going to be
negative two times five plus
negative two times negative three.
Or you could view it as
negative two times five
minus negative two times positive three.
Now let me write those two things down.
So you could do this as negative two
times five,
negative two times five
plus
negative plus negative
two times negative three.
You could view it that way.
Or you could view it as negative two,
negative two times five
minus
and if I'm putting a minus here
then I'm gonna view this
as a positive three,
that we're subtracting a positive three.
So minus
negative two times positive three.
Notice I either wrote the negative here
and wrote a positive here,
or I wrote the negative here
and made this a positive three.
But these are going to be equivalent.
Either way I've distributed
this negative two.
Notice I have a negative two,
negative two.
And what are these going to be equal to?
Well, negative two times
five is negative 10
and then,
and then negative two times negative three
is positive six,
or over here negative two
times three is negative six,
but then we subtract it so
it's just gonna get positive,
you're gonna get positive six either way.
This right over here is positive six
and this over here,
subtracting a negative six
would give you positive six.
So you get negative ten plus six.
And that's this choice right over here.
Which of course does
evaluate to negative four,
which this expression does evaluate to.
This one up here evaluates to negative 16.
And of course I won't select
this because I found an answer.
Let's do several more.
Which of the following
expressions are equivalent
to negative S times T times S?
Select all that apply.
And here we can't just substitute,
we can't just evaluate it and see,
oh what do these evaluate to.
We need to do a little bit of manipulation
of these variables.
Well there's a couple of
ways to think about it.
One, we could change the order in which
we multiply these things.
So we could view this as
negative S, that's that,
let me write it a little bit neater.
We could view it as
negative S times S,
times S times T.
Times, oops, let me do
that in a different color,
times S times T.
Times T.
And do any of the choices look like that?
Well almost.
Instead of saying negative S times S,
this says S times negative S.
And because multiplication, once again,
I'm not a big fan of using the word
because it sounds complicated,
but it's commutative.
A times B is the same thing as B times A.
So I can rewrite this as,
I can rewrite this,
I can swap these two and write this as
S times,
S times negative S times T,
times T.
Times T.
All I did is I swapped these two.
This negative S and this S.
I just swapped them and I got exactly
what I have right over here.
Now let's just make sure
that this one does not apply
and maybe the easiest way
is to try to simplify this.
And the best way I could think about that
is by distributing this S.
So if I distribute this S,
what I'm going to get,
this is going to be equal to
S times T, which is ST.
Or I could even, I can write it like this.
I could write it S times T, like that.
And then I have minus S times S,
so minus S times S.
I could write it that was
or I could write minus
S squared if I want to.
That's the same thing as S times S.
But this is very different.
This is very different.
Here I'm just taking the
product of three variables here,
I have two different terms,
taking the product of two variables here
and then the product I guess you could say
I'm taking S squared or
I'm taking S times S.
So this is not,
this is not the same thing.
Which of the following
expressions are equal
to negative X times,
and then in parentheses
negative Y times X?
And I forgot to mention
it, but like always,
pause the video, try to
work them out by yourself
before I do them.
Alright, select all that apply.
So let's just try to
manipulate this a little bit.
So once again, multiplication,
it's associative.
I could, so it's negative X times,
times negative Y
times X.
So, the way it's written here,
I could do these first, that's essentially
what's written over here.
Or it's associative.
Instead, I could do these first.
And the reason why I find this interesting
is a negative times a negative
is going to be a positive.
So this is going to be the same thing,
this thing over here is
going to be the same thing
as positive X times positive Y.
Negative times a negative is a positive.
So you're gonna get positive X times Y
and then you're multiplying by an X again.
Multiplying by an X again.
Now the other thing we
know about multiplication
is it's commutative.
We can change the order
in which we multiply.
Because I don't see this quite,
I don't see this going on over here yet.
So let's see, if I change the order,
if I put the Xs, if I
multiply the Xs first,
I could write this as,
I could write this as X times X,
X times X times Y,
times Y.
All I did is I swapped these two.
Once again, I can swap the
order when I'm multiplying.
And I don't quite see
this yet, but X times X,
that's the same thing as X squared.
This thing right over
here, that's X squared.
So this is going to be X squared,
X squared times Y, which is exactly
what we have over there.
Now what does this one evaluate to?
Now this one actually
evaluates to a number.
Because regardless of what X you pick,
X minus X, that's going to be zero.
Zero times anything is going to be zero.
So this thing is going
to be equal to zero.
So this is different than
what's going on over here.
So I definitely would not pick that.
Let's do one more.
Which of the following expressions
are equivalent to A times
negative 10 plus 11?
Well once again, you know the instinct
when you see something like this
well I'd love to distribute that A,
it's just sitting there.
So let's do that.
A times negative 10 would
be negative 10 times A,
or negative 10A.
And then A times 11,
so it's gonna be plus,
A times 11 is the same
thing as 11 times A,
which we could write as 11A.
Now which of these choices are that?
Negative 10A plus 11A.
So this is negative 10A plus 11A,
so this one looks right.
Now what about this one?
Well here they just swapped the order.
If you put the 11A first,
you could write it this way.
If you write the 11A first,
we could write
11A
and then we have,
instead of saying it negative 10A,
we just say minus 10A.
Once again I just took,
all I did is I took
this thing and I put it
out front.
So these two things are
actually equivalent.
So I would select that one as well.